Venezuela's economy is in crisis which
has something to do with it's crazy
currency system let's break it down the
government has three official exchange
rates for the venezuelan bolivar 6.3
bolivars to one US dollar if you import
essential goods or if you're just one of
the government's bestest friends ten
bolivars to the dollar if you're
slightly less important and fifty to the
dollar for others but there's a fourth
exchange rate for regular folks on the
black market where a single US dollar
goes for sixty to ninety bolivars one of
the worst consequences of this system
importers can make more money buying
cheap US dollars than selling them on
the black market then they can actually
importing and selling essential goods
the result empty shelves subscribe on
YouTube
follow us on Twitter and like us on
Facebook